a Friday night surprise after weeks of
political and public Pressure David
Johnston stepping down as the special
rapporteur investigating foreign
interference in Canadian elections
Johnson writing in his resignation
letter to the Prime Minister when I
undertook the task of independent
special rapporteur on foreign
interference my objective was to help
build trust in our Democratic
institutions I have concluded that given
the highly partisan atmosphere around my
appointment and work my leadership has
had the opposite effect we had tasked
David Johnston to do the report that he
did and make recommendations he did
excellent work now we're looking at the
next steps this repertoire process
needed to end and we need to have an
open public transparent inquiry in his
initial report Johnston concluded a full
public inquiry was not a suitable option
but the federal government says it's now
considering all options and challenging
the opposition make suggestions about
who could lead this public inquiry what
would the terms of reference be what do
they see as the timelines how do they
deal with the obvious challenge of
respecting Canadian law that protects
some of the most sensitive intelligence
information Trudeau has asked Dominic
LeBlanc to figure out next steps by
Consulting with experts and legal
Scholars some who are already suggesting
an inquiry we need to actually be very
careful with your expectations right
foreign interference is some of the most
close hold intelligence that the
government actually has and we've seen
that in the various leaks that have come
out Johnston's work was overshadowed by
opposition concerns about his
relationship with the Prime Minister and
his family now that he's gone experts
say it's time for politicians to work
together these people have it within
them to do it they need to resist their
worst instincts and get on with the job
to which they are elected and now for
all parties want some input in terms of
who's going to be in charge next the
federal government says it's crucial to
do it right the second time to ensure
there's trust from the public in our
institutions pharah
thank you Richard that's Richard zusman
reporting from Victoria